you already know we live from AZ for the
Super Bowl man look shout out to Def Jam
bootleg head podcast shout out to LRG
markham's is here it's markham's time
[Music]
yo
Shaq yo I'm from the belly you're the
Beast Deli on the Beats Ellie on the
piece Monte Grand Fendi on the brief
Shorty at the crib rubbing on my belly
and my feet while this lame [__]
blowing up a selly for a week I'm an
[__] big fish in a glass bowl let a
[__] feel a little froggy like tadpoles
I blast foes dots like a passcode
rappers get their plaques gold then you
finally [__] they get signed and
exposed as rats dropped from all tours
shows get scrapped fans didn't jump ship
cause they know you can't but Advance
money was paid so you owes it back [__]
I'm from where that let fly drill is on
that let's fly turn the roof up in that
made back to the red sky that potato on
that Barrel get them french fry Brock
Lance get the spinning like an F5 if
it's worn in your family feet somewhere
your mama stay at where your granny be
like where the Backwoods at with a grams
and leaf cause I'm finna roll up a [__]
family tree see me got two steps sure
they say I was too blessed she was
wearing your hoodie but she gave a crew
neck how dudes Flex talking about me
like I move sketch get a fool stretched
up in the air suplex see I was born in
Queens raised in Phoenix I'll be black
and like I came up in the cage with
demons worth the mother I'm here proving
that she raised the genius mom finna put
that broke [__] way beneath us Sonata
rolls up in the woods chosen in the hood
check my lineage little [__] gold up in
the hood sanction who the [__] I don't
know up in the hood I've been outside
since I was like four up in the hood but
that don't mean [__] if I don't get back
to it it's against a [__] moral code to
live that foolish so I put her into a
pour into me cause y'all was there when
I was poor as could be damn bad fitting
afford to defeat blood in my hands back
on the wall it's the wonder why [__]
Resort The Savage before rapping and
roaring strong Road when I snap to the
core ravish and door clap dances your
cabbage no couldn't give a [__] gotta
know I'm nasty this [__] [__] steady
reaching for my last position murk to
hit the scene now they rapping different
liquid past the button I'll pass the
basketball I'm finna ride IG live while
I'm in the sky got the greatest flow on
Earth [__] aside it's a guy ain't no
stopping any second I'll be turning your
top rappers to honorable man inches Merc
I'm like fresh how about slay your dog
they fall flat when I pull up with more
max than the Players Ball So tap in make
it make it cool cause you know plug City
coming for everything we take it all
nickel
did it bootleg cab you already know the
Vibes man we got a [__] home game now
I mean 24-hour notice man let's get it
hey what up y'all appreciate you guys
watching this week's freestyle we're
dropping another one next week and
sometimes we drop more than one in a
week but they're always brought to you
by LRG baby that's right loving me some
LRG always and right now if you go to
the website
l-r-g.com and you use the promo code
bootleg you're gonna get 30 off 30 off
that's almost half
at checkout that's right all right shout
out to LRG one more time L Dash R Dash
g.com and when you check out use that
promo code bootleg and save 30 off the
freestyles we'll be back next week
always brought to you by LRG baby